pourquoi je suis candidat à l'élection
législative et sur la 5e circonscription
de l'hérault pour ce territoire et les
valeurs je veux m'engager demain à
l'assemblée nationale en tant que
nouveaux députés avaient tous les
acteurs économiques
ruraux et sociaux de ce territoire et de
circonspection les élus locaux qui font
un travail de sape extraordinaire et qui
amène à cette circonscription ou plus
haut de ses valeurs et je veux domaine
travailleurs et les atouts de matières
construction l'agriculture la
viticulture la vie associative la vie
sociale et culturelle de cette
circonscription étaient non le potentiel
et sam fan thomas numérique auprès de
ses actions de maintenance entraînant
pourquoi je suis candidat de la droite
et du centre parce que je porte à moi
les valeurs comporter aval ou en effet
les valeurs gaullistes les valeurs
république et les valeurs patriotiques
et nation semaine à l'assemblée
nationale je veux faire remonter montée
je veux le faire avec mais je le tram
dray s'il faut prendre des décisions
importantes pour la france et les
français
vive la république vive la
vive les républicains
[Musique]